[Music]
hello everybody
welcome and good afternoon my name is
anata mati and i'm a professor of
finance and economics here at the
stanford graduate school of business and
echo director
of the corporations and society
initiative cassie
engaging in gsb community and others on
issues that we believe are
truly important is a key mission of
cassie so i want to welcome
you and thank you for joining us and i'm
especially
grateful to our guest stacey mitchell
for joining us today cassie focuses on
governance issues as they
pertain to corporations how do we ensure
that corporations can be trusted
to benefit their stakeholders ultimately
society as a whole without
mistreating deceiving and harming how to
ensure that governments
write and enforce appropriate rules and
the corporations comply with those rules
and what are the roles of employees
customers investors academics courts and
the media
in shaping our private and public sector
institutions
their cultures and their impact on all
of us
amazon the 1.7 trillion dollar
behemoth raises these questions and many
others
that are central to cassie's mission
we've been we've seen almost
weekly examples of many of the subjects
of today's conversation
uh from the conditions of amazon work
warehouses
during the kobe 19 pandemic to the
extreme wealth
generated by amazon founder jeff bezos
during this crisis
to the current house anti-trust
subcommittee report on the power of tech
companies
the issues around tech and society are
complex
so we're fortunate to have a panelist
with us today
with amazingly rich experience to
provide us with insight
stacey mitchell in the words of a recent
new york times
magazine a profile story big profile is
the strategist
of the demise of amazon as we know it
she is the co-director of the institute
of local self-reliance
and the coordinator of athena a
coalition of nearly
50 labor small business and social
justice
groups seeking to rein in amazon's power
stacey will engage in a discussion with
susannah shaddock
an nba 2 and a member of our awesome
cassie student leadership team
team susanna and ben roxanne the
co-chairs of our event committee are
finalizing the details of our next event
which will be on uh november 12th
at 6 15 pm stay tuned for announcements
with darren dodson and talking about the
role of corporations in a social
movement
like black lives matter following the
conversation
uh we will continue the engagement
taking questions from
you the diverse audience now please join
me in thanking again
stacey mitchell and welcome susanna
and stacy thank you thank you so much
anat for that introduction and thank you
stacy for being with us i will go ahead
and
hand the baton to you to talk to us um
and just so the audience knows we'll be
hearing from stacy
uh uninterrupted for about 15 minutes
and then i'll start by asking her some
questions and then we'll open it up to
all of you
to ask questions so please use the q a
feature
to submit any questions you have for
stacey and we will ask them at the end
but stacy take it away well thank you so
much
it's really great to be here and i want
to thank the corporations and society
initiative for
organizing these events and for inviting
me to participate in one it's really
terrific and
thanks for everyone who turned up today
it's um it's nice to have you all here
um so i work for uh i run an
organization called the institute for
local self-reliance we're a national
research
and policy advocacy organization and
we're deeply concerned about
growing levels of corporate
concentration across the economy
and the impact that that's having on
working people
small businesses local communities and
ultimately
our democracy and we're working very
hard to
shift the underlying policies that have
led to that
growing levels of concentration uh
indeed there's research that shows that
of industries have become significantly
more concentrated
uh in the last 10 years or so some of
this concentration we can see
companies like walmart which now
captures one out of every four dollars
that americans spend on groceries
and utterly dominates the grocery market
in about 40
different metro areas we can see it in
the concentration of the airlines
uh in in access to the internet there
are millions of american households
that have either no broadband provider
or only a single choice of broadband
provider
and you know the monopoly power is is
stuff that we can see but it's also
hidden from us
you know you walk down the beer aisle at
your supermarket and you see lots of
different
um choices uh you know some of them kind
of mainstream beer some of them
craft beers most of those choices are
owned by just two companies even many of
the craft brands
are in fact owned by the two companies
that produce about 70 percent of all of
america's beer
in the last few years there's been sort
of a growing attention to this problem
and there's new economic research and
other work that's coming out
showing that concentration is having a
number of very negative effects on the
american economy
we've seen the rate of new business
formation
decline sharply we're now creating new
businesses
at about one-third the rate that we were
a generation ago a really sharp decline
in startups
we're seeing rising levels of inequality
and recently economists have linked that
inequality to growing corporate
concentration that in effect that has
helped to hold down wages uh for many
working people
and we see it in the in the power that
corporations
have over congress and over our laws
that this is also having a negative
impact on
on democracy so that's the sort of
broader
stage of the broader economy but i
wanted to talk some today
about amazon in particular you know
amazon is in some ways a continuation of
these trends
but it's also a kind of different a
different kind of monopoly power if you
will
amazon does so many different things
that it can be hard to
figure out what exactly it is in some
sense
amazon produces hit television shows it
manufactures
clothing and batteries and advanced
computer chips
it offers a satellite based surveillance
system
to police and military clients it owns
twitch which is
the by far and away the dominant video
game streaming service
uh it accounts for about 70 percent of
the smart speaker market
alexa is far and away the dominant voice
platform
amazon's lately built a logistics and
package delivery operation
uh that's beginning to rival ups and the
postal service in the number of packages
that it delivers
it's making forwards forays into health
care into finance
so you know what is this company that
does so many different things what is
the nature of it
i think the way to understand what
amazon is is that it's essentially an
infrastructure company
um it provides the infrastructure that
other participants need to access the
market
so its website its shopping platform
accounts for about 50 percent of all
online shopping
but more significantly in some ways than
even that number
is the fact that about 60 to 65 percent
of the time when americans want to
buy something online they start their
shopping search
at amazon it used to be a few years ago
that they would start to
at a search engine like google and they
would type in the product they were
looking for
running shoes and they would get amazon
but they would get other companies
including even independent local
retailers
and would choose among those options now
most people start right on amazon
and what that means is that if you're a
company that produces or
retails any consumer product you
essentially have to be selling on
amazon's platform
otherwise you're giving up access to a
huge part of the market
most of the market right out of the gate
similarly
amazon owns about a
half of the world's public cloud
computing capacity so it provides
the infrastructure on which a huge
number of other companies and
governments
manage their data and and
and process their data in the cloud uh
increasingly software developers of
course are developing software for the
cloud that means that they're
they have to ride on amazon's rails if
you if you will in order to have their
clients be able to access
uh their products voice is similarly um
the new interface as we increasingly
access the web via voice as we
you know run more and more of our
devices and our appliances
via voice the interface for that
increasingly is
alexa and so again another point of
infrastructure that lots of other
companies depend on if they want to
actually reach
users so how exactly
um did amazon become so dominant you
know how did it become
this company through which huge numbers
of other companies have to go through
a gatekeeper if you will in order to
reach the market
um the answer to that is is of course
there are multiple things but
the one i want to highlight today is
that amazon very much exploited
changes and openings in public policy
you know in particular we made some
changes in how
we interpret and enforce the antitrust
laws
beginning in the 1980s and as a result
amazon has been able to grow using
tactics that would have
invited criminal prosecution
uh had they happened at an earlier point
in history
for example predatory pricing and this
is
uh when you sell goods at a loss
in order to put smaller competitors who
can't
afford to lose that much money out
so for the first six years that amazon
was in existence it sold books
exclusively and it sold books at a loss
it lost about three billion
dollars in six years and lots of
competing book retailers
did not have the wherewithal did not
have the backing from wall street
to match those prices and they went out
and amazon now very much dominates the
book market with more than 50
of all book sales similarly in the
in the mid 2000s when a number of
companies came along to compete with
amazon
in online retail companies like zappos
and diapers.com
amazon sold you know first shoes and
then diapers
uh it's steep losses in fact it lost
about 200 million dollars a month
selling diapers at a loss those
companies were much smaller
they couldn't withstand the same losses
and
they eventually agreed to be bought out
by amazon and so
predatory pricing was a way to eliminate
upstart competition in the online retail
market
and there are a number of other kinds of
tactics that again would have been
illegal under an earlier approach to
antitrust
but which changed in the 1980s for
example something that's known as
monopoly leveraging or
tying so an example of this is how is it
that amazon in a matter of a few years
became this giant
shipping and package delivery operation
how did it build a ups
essentially within its uh within its
existing corporate structure
almost overnight and the answer is that
it it required all of the companies that
are selling on its platform
it's that if you want to actually show
up in search results and be positioned
so that you can make sales you need to
use our warehousing and fulfillment
services
uh and so instead of having to compete
on price and service
with ups and the postal service it
essentially
used its hold on on those third-party
sellers
to build up a huge business
leveraging its dominance in one area to
become dominant in
a different part of the economy
altogether we see that over and over
again with amazon and part of the reason
it has
you know all of these different is
involved in all of these different
business lines as it becomes dominated
one and then uses that power
and the insights that it gets from all
of the data that it's able to
to receive to move into adjacent
industries one after the other
so what what all of this sort of
one of the things that this all comes
down to in terms of what are the
consequences of this
you know i think we should understand
amazon
as increasingly a kind of governing
force
that in effect amazon is a private
regulator of
our markets if you can even call them
markets anymore
so in a democracy you know a market is a
free and open space that exists in the
context of
publicly determined rules
um and everyone has more or less equal
access to it
but now more and more of our commerce is
not happening in a public market it is
happening in a private arena that is
controlled by amazon
so whether you succeed or fail and
selling online
is largely dependent on whether or not
how amazon treats you whether it
discriminates against your business or
offers you more favorable positioning
amazon determines winners and losers uh
increasingly because of that power
it also sets the rules it defines the
terms and the
policies essentially that govern that
market and
like uh you know it's not a democratic
form of government either it's an
autocrat it can suddenly
change those rules um where somebody
who's built up a business
uh selling on amazon suddenly fines
overnight the rules are different and
their business is no longer viable
they can even have their account
suspended overnight or discover that
amazon has increased its fees
substantially and now
uh their business no longer no longer
works
and amazon is is a tax collector through
the fees that it charges
to get through its gates and absent real
competition
it's been able to substantially increase
those fees on third-party sellers
over time so they're paying higher and
higher
rents if you will to amazon this kind of
power is i think fundamentally at odds
with democracy and the notion of
liberty the notion of equality and it
has
a lot of consequences in terms of
our lives and the health of our
communities
it means that many independent
businesses both
producers of goods publishers
manufacturers
are increasingly live and die
by amazon's dictates and over time
amazon is taking over more and more
of the market and they are being
squeezed out and closing
independent small businesses small-scale
manufacturers
brands of all kinds are falling by the
wayside
and there is less and less diversity
in the market uh fewer new ideas are
being developed and and being able to
find an audience because
everything is collapsing into this
single into the single pipeline
and that loss of businesses um
and that loss of startups and kind of
dynamism
has a negative effect on people's wages
particularly at the lower end because
there's less competition for labor
and it also has a really negative effect
on the vitality of our communities
we are increasingly divided into a
handful of metro areas
that are seeing some level of prosperity
and then
lots of regions of the country sort of
other cities
small towns rural areas that are losing
businesses
losing jobs and where i think where
circumstances are increasingly bleak
and that is tearing really the fabric of
our society
and our democracy ultimately
so uh the question then to turn to as i
as i close here is so so what do we what
is the solution to that and i know
um suzanne and i will talk about this
more kind of in the q a and in the
questions that you bring
there has been a growing movement
growing attention to the problem of
monopoly power
and to what happened to our anti-trust
laws
and that's coming partly from economists
and scholars who've been doing research
in this area
that has begun to connect some of these
dots it's coming from journalists who
are doing really good reporting
it's coming from policy makers who are
recognizing that this there's a real
problem with extreme concentration
and from advocacy organizations like
ours and and many others
last week the in part as a result of
that advocacy in that activity
last week the house anti-trust
subcommittee
released the findings of a 15-month
investigation into the power of big
the market power of big tech companies
apple google facebook and amazon
and laid out a set of recommendations
those recommendations for first of all
the report
includes hundreds of pages of evidence
they interviewed
tons of witnesses uh gathered millions
of documents from the companies and and
so on
and presented i think a fairly
extensive and comprehensive uh case
uh for the fact that there is market
power uh concentrated market power and
that these companies are
abusing it and then laid out a set of
recommendations um
that include splitting amazon and other
tech giants up along business lines so
spinning off
um those separate businesses into new
companies
and eliminating some of those underlying
conflicts of interest and the
ability to self-deal to preference your
own interest against
others to require that companies that
that function as infrastructure
to say you have a higher obligation just
as we have done with railroads and
telephone wires in the past
to say you need to treat all comers
equally
you need to have rules of fair dealing
and non-discrimination
you can't use that gatekeeper power to
gouge and disadvantage other businesses
and finally to the sort of a third set
of recommendations was around restoring
our anti-trust laws
so that things like predatory pricing um
are not happening that there's a higher
standard
to block those kinds of practices so i
think that the report has a great set of
recommendations and we're now sort of
moving into looking at
uh moving towards trying to get
legislation to actually implement those
recommendations
so i will leave it there fantastic oh my
gosh
so much to dig into um any of my
classmates who are on the call will know
that these topics are some of my
favorite to discuss
um thank you for sharing with us i think
i first want to start by asking a
question that i feel
obligated to ask as somebody who is at
business school we're speaking to a
business school audience
you know there's sort of um a bias in
the business school community often
towards free markets and this idea that
the invisible hands
of the market will sort things out and
prevent
these kinds of problems from happening
and so i'm curious to get your
perspective
you know what would milton friedman say
about amazon does does the story of
amazon really run counter to
his free market narrative um you talked
about some of the regulatory failures
that enabled amazon to get to where it
is today but i'm curious what you think
the market failures might have been
yeah yeah exactly well um you know to
milton friedman so he
defined a monopoly and i'll actually
quote here a monopoly exists when a
specific enterprise has sufficient
control
over a particular product or service to
determine significantly the terms on
which others have access to it
so that was his definition of what a
monopoly is it's when you control
something and you can dictate terms
essentially
so i'm thinking and there are lots of
different kinds of stories that i could
tell about this but the one that came to
mind immediately was
a small book publisher called melville
house
and a number of years ago they were in
negotiations with
amazon over the discount rate that they
would be giving to amazon
and whatever other terms for their uh
for their contract
and melville was sort of holding firm on
some of its terms and amazon didn't like
that and melville house woke up one day
and amazon had removed the buy
button from every one of its titles
suddenly you could not actually buy any
of its books
um amazon has over 50 percent of the
entire book market
and so overnight melville houses sales
dropped
many of its authors especially people
who are releasing new books right
about that time you know that early days
of a new book is so important
um i mean just overnight they're they're
just really hurt
by that um threatening the existence of
the company um
all together um and uh
melville house gave in you know they
agreed to amazon's terms
uh and part of those terms meant that
amazon got a sweetheart deal you know
more of a sweet
terms while competing booksellers
including independent booksellers got
worse terms
from melville house because they didn't
have that sort of muscle and so
the result was like furthering amazon's
uh market power within the book industry
so to milton friedman's definition
that's a monopoly that's when you have
that sort of power you can dictate
um and in this case mobile house really
didn't have alternatives they weren't
able to say you know what you're only 10
of the market so we're going to take our
business elsewhere if you don't want to
negotiate with us on these terms
so you know i think um markets are
fantastic
and they really do a lot of things that
are are brilliant
um and as i alluded to in my talk i
don't think that
markets really have failed i think
policy has failed
and you know markets only exist in the
context of
agreed-upon rules um in some sort of
social
uh process by which you enforce those
rules
um you know we're two villages trading
with one another and i just show up with
a bunch of armed people one day and we
just steal your stuff i mean that's not
a market right so there have to be
agreements and rules
um that prevent coercion and that enable
there to be a measure of equality and
freedom in order to actually make
markets work and that requires public
rules
so again i think the question is where
did the rules go wrong where did policy
go wrong
that enabled this one entity to become
so dominant that it can tell other
people what to do
yeah yeah that's a great point and that
connect i think to something that you
wrote
um in your 2018 article for the nation
um you wrote amazon is moving us away
from a democratic political economy
in which commerce takes place in open
markets governed by public rules
and toward a future in which the
exchange of goods occurs in a private
arena governed by amazon
you spoke a little bit about that in in
your introductory remarks but i'd love
to dig into this
and just for some context just last week
cassie hosted
a conversation about how technology
companies and specifically some of these
internet platform companies
can undermine democratic ideas and
processes
so i'm curious do you think that
amazon's business
model is inherently at odds with
the political economy of liberal
democracies
yes i do um i think because it is really
sort of in some ways usurping the role
of government
you know um they you know the
the the rules that they set for their
marketplace governs
a huge percentage of the online market
um and that's of course true uh
increasingly with
software and the cloud it's true in the
voice market
uh where companies need to be able to
collect connect to alexa and integrate
with alexa and therefore
are subject to amazon's terms for for
doing that and to amazon's surveillance
which is something you know i didn't
talk touch on it maybe enough in the
opening remarks which is part of
you know being the infrastructure means
that not only do you get to set the
terms
and you know sort of pick winners and
losers
but you have a god-like view of all of
this activity occurring in the market
and you can see what your competitors
are doing you can see
into uh industries that you're not in
yet and you can see
uh uh and activity in those industries
and then you can decide which of these
industries is lucrative where do we want
to go and you move into that
market with a built-in advantage that
well everyone else is operating in the
dark
you are the only one with that kind of
uh incredible
uh view and ability to surveil
what's happening across all of these
different all of these different markets
that's just an incredibly powerful um
place to be um and you know we do see
something about you know there are you
know
i don't know how many um hundreds of
thousands of businesses
that you know really depend on amazon in
order to reach the online market
you know companies that in some cases a
number of years ago
had you know their own websites and
doing their own traffic but as
people no longer use search engines and
found them and all the traffic just
started at amazon
they had little choice but to sell on
that platform and i think that's what's
really crucial
i interview third party sellers a lot
and third-party sellers can be anywhere
from like large manufacturers that you
know brand names that you would know
that are selling on the platform to an
independent brick and mortar retailer to
a web only retailer um
and you know when i talk to them you
know they're like yeah i'm on these
other platforms i'm on
walmart's platform i'm on ebay but the
share of sales happening through those
places is minuscule
um everything is through amazon and so
if they decide tomorrow to cancel my
account or to demote me in the search
results or to take
you know one of the things the wall
street journal has reported on is
spying on on popular products and then
making a knockoff version of your
product and suddenly
amazon's version of it is is ranking
right there at the top
one of the things that amazon has been
able to do with this position of power
which is a governing power is to levy a
growing tax
so last year the average share
the average cut of every sale by a
third-party seller that amazon took was
five years ago was 19 and so
uh what we're seeing is that most of
these businesses that are selling on
amazon's platform
they may generate revenue initially but
they're not actually profitable and
many of them are failing most of the
vast majority of them are failing uh and
not actually succeeding on the platform
so yeah i think in those ways it's a
direct threat to democracy because it's
structuring our markets it's playing the
role of government and then when you
combine that with just the political the
lobbying ability
the growing presence of amazon and dc
that's another
another set of problems super
fascinating there are a bunch of really
great questions coming in from the
audience so i'll just
ask one more question before um
transitioning to audience questions
um so i read a very interesting wired
article last night by
eli pariser about um
using the analogy of the transition from
sort of private walled
pleasure gardens to public parks
as a way to sort of make a
recommendation for one path forward
specifically talking about internet
platform companies and i think more
sort of public square common spaces
where people can communicate online but
i think
um you know based on everything that
you've been saying around amazon sort of
privatizing
commerce on the internet i'm curious if
you feel
like there might be an opportunity in
addition to the regulation
recommendations that you already covered
from
the antitrust committee's um report you
know is there maybe an opportunity for
uh the creation of a public e-commerce
space that um is more controlled by
you know the public sector and is uh
held for the common good
in the same way that parks were created
to create these public spaces accessible
to all
yeah it's a really interesting question
you know i think
um you know as i mentioned before i do
think amazon's
marketplace that's her website needs to
be spun off from the rest of amazon so
amazon is a retailer as a separate
company amazon is a logistics and
shipping provider is separate aws the
web
the cloud stuff is separate so you end
up with a stand-alone company that
is a marketplace um for consumers and
for
for buyers and sellers can meet
and because it's so dominant that needs
some level of public oversight in terms
of saying look you're a common carrier
you've got to have um you've got to have
rules that
treat everybody equally you can't
discriminate you can't gouge
so that begins to get you a step closer
to something that is public in the sense
that it is um
almost like a regulated utility maybe
kind of a model
um has these public interest obligations
what i think would then be great is if
we then saw
other shopping platforms arise once we
sort of you know check amazon's monopoly
power
does that then create space for other
versions and so you know some of those
maybe existing ones like etsy could grow
for example or something like that
and i think it's interesting you think
about well is there a public model
perhaps
more relevant would be the notion of a
cooperatively owned model
uh owned by businesses selling on the
platform so similar to
like ace hardware eight people think ace
is a chain but in fact it's all
independent hardware
stores and they collectively own a
wholesaling operation
um so they're able to do joint buying
and warehousing and all of that
and to share the ace brand but the
stores are independent and they
they have a voting control over ace the
the larger entity so we could have
something like that as
a platform and i think the other part of
amazon's business that stands out
whether
too that stands out from a public
standpoint
the logistics operation um we have the
postal service which is a great
institution um employs people at union
wages
has a mission to serve all parts of the
country equally
and so has a democracy leveling kind of
mission
baked right into what it does i'm deeply
worried about the impact that amazon has
had on the postal service
and is continuing to have on the postal
service so when i think about
sort of the public role in that part of
amazon's business
it is in really shoring up the postal
service
and making sure that that incredible
public asset remains
a public asset got it great
okay so on to questions from the
audience the first question
um in your introductory remarks it seems
like amazon is more detrimental to
suppliers rather than consumers do you
see a difference between the effect of a
monopoly like drug companies which can
overcharge dependent consumers
and a monops sony like walmart which can
keep prices low for consumers by
bullying
its suppliers that's a really great
question
when our anti-trust laws were passed you
know beginning
in the 19th century and then with
subsequent
additional laws in the 1910s and the
1930s and
50s the laws really had a broad
uh purpose around maintaining
market structures that were fair and
open and
protecting all market players interests
and having a fair and open
markets and so they were about
protecting consumers from monopoly power
but also
uh protecting us as producers of value
um
so as people who work and need to earn a
living or people who want to start and
run a business
who grow food or whatever it may be when
we're producing value
the idea is you're also protected by the
antitrust laws
and this notion that a monopoly is that
as the questioner rightly
points out if you get that kind of power
you can
take from different sides of the market
so you can
charge higher prices to consumers but
you can also exploit your monopoly to
um to squeeze producers
so in the 1980s when we had this
real shift in our anti-trust policy a
center
part of that was we changed the idea of
what antitrust was for
instead of being about this bigger
picture of
maintaining competition and fairness
we in preventing outsized concentrations
of power
instead the thinking was the only goal
of antitrust should be maximizing
efficiency
and baked within that was this idea that
bigger companies are inherently more
efficient which is not actually true but
that was an assumption that was made
and so it basically turned antitrust on
its head and
we began to have a policy that actually
encouraged concentration and a lot of
that was done in the name of lowering
prices for consumers
more efficiency lower prices and so part
of how amazon and walmart and these
other companies
have been able to become so big is that
they have not used their monopoly power
particularly against consumers although
there are some examples of that
they've mostly used it to take from us
as producers
so part of the the kind of revolution in
thinking that is happening right now
in this area of law is this sort of
recognition that like our well-being
actually depends not only on our ability
to be treated fairly as consumers but on
our ability to actually earn a decent
living and so this connection to
inequality and concentrated power is
really
important so there are some differences
in terms of how that plays
out in the law but i think what we're
seeing in general is this
move to having a broader definition
again and recognizing that monopoly
harms aren't just about prices but also
about wages and
earnings for producers yeah yeah that
makes a lot of sense
um another question here what are your
thoughts on
amazon's m a strategy and specifically
amazon's
acquisition of whole foods oh yeah
so amazon has acquired a lot of
companies uh many of them quite small so
small that they didn't trigger
any sort of notice or review to the
anti-trust agencies whole foods was an
exception to that that
of course did trigger a review
amazon has has used acquisitions to
gain control of pivotal new technologies
and to prevent
other market players from getting access
to those technologies
so one example of this is the the very
um
intricate and incredible robots that was
around inside
amazon's warehouses um those were
created by a company called kiva
which amazon bought in i think it was
2012 but i'm not quite sure
the year right and when amazon bought
that company it immediately canceled
kiva's
contracts with all these other retailers
who relied on those
robots in their warehouses so now amazon
has the best technology out there and
it's blocked its competitors from having
access
to it um you know so there are lots of
examples of this
with regard to whole foods the you know
it's a good illustration of how the
antitrust agencies have gone wrong
because it didn't get it didn't get
what's known as a second
request meaning that they in 30 days
they looked at it and said okay it's
fine you know very quickly they didn't
look into it any deeper
um and we don't know because they don't
explain their decisions which is one of
the problems with policy right now
but what we assume is that they looked
at that in this and they said well
amazon's a fairly tiny player in
groceries and
whole foods is tiny in groceries so you
can put the two together no big deal in
groceries
but that was i think a mistaken way to
understand it because amazon has
monopoly power in the online market and
buying whole foods was a way to shore up
its market power online
groceries is a really pivotal pivotal
part of what we buy because we grocery
shop so often
it's a huge portion of our spending and
it influences other kinds of
spending decisions that we make and so
um having a grocer is really sort of
critical
if you don't if you don't figure out a
grocery strategy online then you're
going to miss
part of the retail market and if
somebody else gets it they're then going
to be
in an advantageous position so buying
whole foods as a way to shore that up it
also gave amazon 400
and some prime locations in
these sort of more affluent kinds of
markets where
it could set up last mile delivery
points so part of amazon's logistics
strategy whole foods played an important
role in as it transitioned into being
this dominant logistics provider
and it gave amazon incredible cache of
new data
about how we behave when we're shopping
in a store
about how the industry works how the
grocery industry works and amazon is now
talking about building you know they're
going to build a supermarket chain
different from whole foods
with thousands and thousands of
locations across the country
so all of those things are to say that
that was an acquisition that was done in
service of
entrenching monopoly power and therefore
i would say
is illegal and unfortunately the
antitrust agencies looked at it in this
very narrow way
and didn't connect those dots and really
looked at it in an analog way without
really understanding digital markets
yeah that's fascinating i mean i know
certainly as a consumer who's gone to
whole foods both before and after that
acquisition that
for my end the prices dropped pretty
significantly
um but it's very interesting to hear
some of the other
strategic advantages that whole foods
gave amazon
um we have a another question here about
amazon's relationship with
space through aws and blue origin
and the question is will this
relationship with space give amazon
a global supranational power
outside of any u.s control or
regulations
actually an intergalactic monopoly
here yeah great question
um you know some of you who uh
are uh pay attention to jeff bezos as
much as i do may know that
his overriding interest is in space
um and indeed there's some speculation
that the reason he's built this huge
empire and
made himself incredibly rich is uh in
order to finance
uh expeditions into space and um
so yeah there's some good stuff out
there there's a
pbs frontline documentary on amazon that
touches on some of this
uh if you if you kind of want to explore
more his his thinking around
around space and also there was a cover
story in the atlantic i think about a
year ago
um that looked at some of this as well
um i am concerned about
uh you know amazon's got these sort of
growing roles that are
surveillance roles so they've got a
satellite-based
surveillance system that they market to
police and military clients
and what is different about what amazon
offers compared to what's gone before is
that it's near real time
so before you know as i understand it
you sort of would have to
you know there would be a delay in the
imagery that you were getting and you'd
have to sort of set up set
set up for the next satellite pass to do
the kind of you know get the shot that
you needed
so there's always this delay but amazon
has
created a way where it's near real time
so the ability for police
say to intervene in a demonstration or
for military action
or the like to happen is substantially
enhanced by this
and of course it gives amazon and
whatever other corporate clients
subscribe to it
just an incredible view about what
people
what people are doing on top of that
they've started a satellite internet
service
i'm not totally sure what that is about
it'll be interesting to see that how
that unfolds a global thing they say
it's to get people online around the
world
and then they've bought this home um
they brought
a company called euro which is a mesh
network
for home routers the leading mesh
um which seems to be sort of a further
bid
around being able to have
a complete view into what's happening in
our homes and our offices i should say
in other workplaces
um where not only will you know sort of
what's going through
alexa in terms of like who's at your
door on your ring doorbell and who's
you know what settings you're using on
your washing machine and what you're
asking
the internet for it's on what services
you subscribe to
but now actually be able through having
the the
your control over your router know which
devices are being used and sort of the
level of traffic and
again a kind of surveillance for
commercial purposes but also one that
feels
really eerie to me so i don't know how
that relates to space but it's certainly
you know this is not a company or an
individual who
thinks small about his ambitions
yeah space seems to be a common thread
among billionaires
these days between jesus and elon musk
it's like
a giant race um okay i know we have
about five minutes left so
um maybe one more question from the
audience and then we can
we can wrap up but um one audience
member asks
how do you see the role of amazon in
addressing societal issues such as
climate change
does bezos's earth fund reflect an
individual philanthropic decision
or a strategic move on behalf of amazon
well that's very interesting um you know
there are amazon employees who have
organized a um you know
have organized amongst themselves to
push amazon on climate and have done a
number of
demonstrations some of them actually
were fired in part because of their
for their activism um so i definitely um
look to them and i apologize for not
immediately remembering the name of
their
group but you could probably find it
online and i would sort of defer to them
for their perspective on what they think
amazon should be doing in that area
and you know whether it's actually
doing what it's saying that it's doing i
do think sort of broadly
a couple of comments i um
i am concerned about how we starve the
public sector of resources
um in part because companies like amazon
dodge
paying taxes amazon paid in the last few
years has paid effectively no federal
taxes
and in in seattle it's home city
it's fought very hard against
attacks on larger companies to help deal
with new challenges like homelessness
so they are very much a tax dodger they
have a long history of dodging
local state and national taxes and
manipulating the rules in that area so
as we starve
the public sector we are less able as a
society
to make the investments and the shifts
that we need to make in order to
uh reduce our our climate pollution
and that's very concerning and so then
to to do that on the one hand and then
to step in and position
oneself as uh you know savior on the
problem
um i think is really problematic and
gets back to my
sort of broader critique which is like
who who is in charge you know are we
members of a democratic society where we
set the rules
are we you know outcomes on things like
climate and workplace safety
and competition you know increasingly um
determined by
this sort of autocrat um and i and i
think that that's really problematic
great well um we're almost at the end
as i promised i i would love to ask you
one final question before we close which
is
really what we as business school
students and future business leaders
who may go on to work at amazon or other
companies that
have this increasingly monopolistic
power in the market
what should we be doing what can we do
um
to help make sure that the markets are
more fair and equitable and open to
everyone
yeah it's a great question you know i
think um
you know a lot of people uh will will
get in touch with me and say well i'm
gonna cancel my prime account and
let's you know boycott amazon and that
sort of thing and i'm just not
i don't think that as consumers that
this is on us or that we're going to
solve this problem
and i should also say that i very much
see the future in which
we can benefit from all of the great
things that technology has done and
online shopping and having packages at
our doorsteps and all the things that we
love
but can do so in a way where we open up
these markets
and where we have more competition
instead of this sort of dominance and so
it's not about giving up technology or
giving up any of that
great convenience it's more about
shifting the rules so that we really
have open markets
um so i don't think it's on us as
consumers and i don't think it's on us
you know in that kind of capacity i
think really it's about
rediscovering our citizenship muscle um
and you know we need uh uh
we really need congress uh and our
anti-trust agencies but particularly
congress
to step in and get antitrust law
back on track to do the hard work of
thinking about
how are our digital markets working how
are they not working
what do we need to do in order to
address the
huge myriad of problems that we're
seeing across these
different companies and sectors and so
i was really i found that the house
antitrust subcommittee's
you know your 15-month investigation was
really incredible
because it illustrated congress's
ability to deeply investigate a problem
it was bipartisan um even many of the
findings were bipartisan in part because
they went on a journey together and
really looked at the facts and came up
with a shared set of facts
and and share indeed many of the
recommendations but not all of them
um that's an illustration of congress
actually working of doing its job of
using its incredibly
powerful investigatory tools which it
has not really used much in a number of
decades certainly not in the area of
monopoly since the 1970s the last time
we had an investigation like this
so i'm really encouraged by this but
what's going to now make
those recommendations move is if other
members of congress
are hearing from constituents
and so this is about you know asking for
meetings with your member of congress
with their staff saying are you looking
at this
i'm i work in technology i believe in
this
sector but things have gone off the
rails and we need to
we need to address those problems so i
think it's really about engaging on that
level as a citizen
awesome well thank you so much stacy for
joining us today
and thank you to everybody who attended
we are thrilled to have another event
coming up on november 12th
around the role that corporations can
play in social movements like black
lives matter with darren dodson
um so please stay tuned but for now
thank you again stacey and thank
you everyone we'll let you go enjoy the
rest of your day
you